[Musik]
erst wieder ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut uns auf wir
haben gerade weil es später durch mein
handy gar nicht bei dir auf jeden fall
ist schon nach 11 uhr und weise hat sich
der markt erklärte der kamera hallo und
bis heute dieses video mal eben schnell
zu film weil ich das endlich jetzt mal
gedreht haben wollte das ding ist
nämlich die ganzen sachen dazu die habe
ich schon vorbestellt sie sind auch
schon recht lange angekommen und zwar
geht es heute um die lustigsten oder
ich heiße nicht lustig so hätten falsche
ausgesucht das sind alles sehr coole
produkte für die küche benutzen kann
alles so fürchten gadgets küchen helfen
alles verstellt von meiner lieblings
plattform ruhig ich habe auf ebene von
einkauf bzw
ich würde sagen ich zeigt auf jeden fall
kurz die sachen und dann probiert wir
die auch direkt mal aus dass du lust auf
so bendix
nein nein kann dir nicht okay was
wahrscheinlich hast du das sagen haben
ach so leute und das hier sind noch die
sachen die ich schon eingekauft habe die
wir für das heutige video brauchen wir
brauchen alles außer die tomaten und die
silhouette und zwar ich habe sogar schon
angekündigt hatte manche gehen müssen
runter gehen das ist immer so scheiße
ich muss so lange unter scrollen muss
ich auch nur ansatzweise irgendein
produkt davon für möckel auf fünf
verschiedene küchen geld schutz habe ich
bestellt ich habe dann einfach kittstein
gegeben und dann die coolsten genommen
haben halt alle sachen schon einmal
aufgemacht damit ich die von dem ganzen
anderen boxen aufgestellt anschlag evd
sieht trist mehr glas öffner also fand
ich eigentlich noch richtig gute idee
weil es wenn glas und auch chris kannst
du deshalb nutzen
ob das funktioniert oder nicht müssen
wir gleich mal testen das nächste
produkt das ich bestellt habe und dass
es so was gibt mir eigentlich genial für
die deutschen die keine spülmaschine
haben so wie wir zum beispiel haben wir
hier multifunktionale silikon handschuhe
für geschirrspüler schrauber
also also so heißt es das heißt das sind
handschuhe die zieht man an
und dann kann man damit spülen wie genau
das funktioniert probieren wir gleich
aus das fand ich auch ganz nice wobei
ich das schon irgendwann mal gesehen
habe
das produkt gar nicht mehr ist es zeit
für mich auf jeden fall war das so eine
waffe pancake dingen das platziert man
in der pfanne und erkan darin vier
pancakes gleichzeitig machen das ist
halt so eine vorband 190 gekostet habe
ich mal mitgenommen ist eigentlich schon
durch prime kunde oder so das ist doch
sowas gibt es nicht aber ich habe
bestimmt weltweit zu den 1000 besten
kunden von denen aber ich glaube hier
ging als feature vor allem an so viel
gekocht wie ich hast du so was schon mal
gesehen ja echt klar hat jetzt auch gar
nicht
also ich hab ich habe so was noch nie
gesehen wahrscheinlich ist es in den
kommentaren sofort alex wirst du stellst
du kennt doch jeder
na gut und zu guter letzt noch einen
ganz bestätigen
doch das ist dann auch nicht so richtig
spannend und zwar ein rettig schneider
für karotten 2 gemacht das habe ich das
habe ich noch nicht gesehen ich auch
nicht deswegen habe ich gleich noch
mitgenommen da kann man seine gurke
reinschieben
natürlich sagen mit dem ersten produkt
was ich euch eben gezeigt habe dieser
mehrfach glas öffner ist finde ich an
geister vor allem kommen wir die
qualität davon ist auch teilweise das
ist gar nicht so plastik pur
das heißt wahrscheinlich auch noch nie
im leben gesehen oder sowas ja also ich
hab selber noch nie in der hand hast du
kannst du sagen so weit dass du es
vielleicht doch ja was hast du da warst
oder könnte aber es geht ja auch darum
so wenn leute sowas brauchen und es in
meinem video gut ist es war ja sehr
günstig weißt du dann können jetzt auch
da bestellen ja es ist ein cooles gadget
auf jeden fall wird checken jetzt
erstmal ab ich habe hier marmelade
gekocht die wollte ich immer schon mal
haben
ob das denn funktioniert hier wie es mir
vorstelle
und jetzt drücke ich hier drauf
das hatte ich mir ganz anders
vorgestellt vielleicht an diesen zwei
stunden braucht doch vielleicht bin ich
fast dass die scheiß also so gesehen
da habe ich direkt erst mal eine ganz
schlechte rezensionen was hat das
gekostet was hab ich eben gesagt 91
nicht willst du das haben geschenke ich
das mal was das gibt's doch nicht oder
also jetzt hätte ich das schon mal kurz
vielleicht sagen weil es mag zwar aber
ich glaube ich habe fast gar nicht mehr
testen das ist einfach mal hier an den
teller gras also ich glaube das ist
kompletter bot also hiermit geht es auf
jeden fall nicht leichter also mal
einfach selber hand anlegen soll ja
dafür da sein mit kraft aufzuwenden wird
auf jeweils das ist uns nicht auf keinen
fall
naja also erstes produkt schon meinen
dicken daumen nach unten
und du willst mir sagen dass du so was
schon mal gesehen hat so was kommt als
nächstes haben wir hier diese fans jetzt
einfach mal schädel hilfe für gemüse
oder sonstige zutaten oder probiert es
einfach mal anhand dieser möhre manchmal
ein mal hier und mal checken ob das geht
das schon nicht schlecht denn was willst
du denn mit diesen scheiß klingen da
also mit welchen ja mit diesen eine form
kennst du dich karotten sala also dass
man da die ganze karotte weg hat es auf
jeden fall einige zeit vergangen ganz
schön anstrengen im handwerk mal gut kam
recht jetzt ist genug karotten heute
also muss ich sagen finde ich in ordnung
ich glaube das war nicht mal ein euro
gekostet was wir machen müssen weiter
ist der boden hier dreckig was hier
passiert wenn man das eigentlich küchen
geld schützt kann man schon sagen oder
bevor ich aber zu meinen lieblings gerd
schütz komme heute noch
dass sie einmal testen was marke von
ewig kennt und mag von ganz oft bei
sowie die aber nicht wissen wofür das
gut ist ich zeig euch gar kein problem
wir machen nämlich jetzt auf ganz
entspannt eine tomaten karotten salat
und zwar stecken wir das ganze jetzt
hier in die tomate glaube ich genau
gemacht und jetzt brauche ich nichts
mehr tun außer jetzt was auch wir das
machen wir es noch mal hier
professionell so viel braucht mal eine
wand der will ja gut also ich weiß es
nicht kann auch daran liegen dass eine
tomate jetzt nicht das optimale gemüse
dafür ist mahlzeit vielleicht ein
bisschen zu weich ist es funktioniert
aber ich jetzt mir irgendwie besser
vorgestellt
[Musik]
oder findest du sieht lecker aus
gut jetzt nichts immerhin gesund hier ok
leider
jetzt machen wir also ich habe richtig
bock tor wird ein paar leckere pancakes
zu essen und zwar brauchen wir dafür
dieses produkt ich frag mich nur gerade
wenn man das jetzt in die pfanne tut
schmilzt das nicht das zeug schon oder
ich muss mir noch mal kurz produkte
anschauen saison nicht so gut man ist
hier ein anderes gefunden das muss man
schon so in die pfanne legen finde ich
aber nie ein bisschen krass verpassen
natürlich bei uns ausprobiert erstmal
müssen wir noch kurz die pantec messe
fertig machen muss sagen aber jetzt ein
paar pancakes für mit einem teller reis
oder marzipan table machst du das
und marx meinte gerade pancakes machen
es schwierig ist es wirklich also aber
das ist glaube ich jetzt keine
hygienischen sind sollten wir das
wenigstens mal vorher getrennt weil ich
will gar nicht wissen was für
chinesische im italien der dritten mal
drauf jetzt so oder so
[Musik]
das liegt auch an diesem komischen ding
oder ich habe keine ahnung ich bin
überfordert meiner mama ob das ding
bringt also die pfanne brät das ding ist
[Musik]
einmal appendix reinwald also ich glaube
irgendwie das ist nicht ganz richtig
vielleicht gesagt haben weil die von
unseren fans leute mein fehler ich habe
respekt und er ist versuchen wir das mal
richtig reinzulegen leute das sieht auch
schon besser aber musste das ja
theoretisch auch gleich wenden
eigentlich kann man das mit dem ding
vielleicht also an den seiten zieht also
drin dafür das macht auch sinn weil
daheim sind was sie sind das problem bei
diesem chat ist dass da irgendwie ne zu
kasse spannung drin ist und das bleibt
nicht ganz auf dem boden das heißt ja
immer und eine kleine stelle die offen
ist wo dann halt dieser pancake raus
fließen kann so dass es gar nicht
unbedingt grund ist aber jetzt warum
trieben auch nicht schön soll's wir
haben einen haben wir noch ein haben
dann auch naja 22 einmal in die
kommentare hashtag alex ist unfähig
abziehen
ich finde das ist kompletter müll dieses
ding kommen ich kann man lieber einen
reinen tröpfeln und das play besser das
unten verbrennt das halt viel zu schnell
guck dir das mal an ich mache ich habe
doch in meinem leben schon mal pancakes
gemacht sie sind oben nicht mal
ansatzweise fertig und von unten brandy
wieso also das sage jetzt nicht das sagt
man ist nicht an mir am ende oder nein
sie nicht aber das gelte trägt nicht
dazu bei wie schnell oder langsam das
brät aber es ist halt einfach scheiße
aber dadurch dass das gadget überhaupt
da ist werden die halt so nach oben
getürmt und die können gar nicht von der
einen seite durch sein bevor man sie
drehen kann weil die oberhand noch nicht
durch sind weiß ich meinen sollte ich
muss dir sind abzugshaube dran lassen
weil sonst kann man sie nicht aushalten
jetzt stinkt so verbrannt wir müssen
jetzt aber sauber machen und dadurch
natürlich darauf vorbereitet und habe
mir diese reinigungs handschuhe oder
spüle hans nur das hier funktionieren
also praktisch wie einen schwamm
handschuhe zusammen so also man kann ihr
spiel drauf machen und dann spielen
wir testen jetzt noch tiger diese
mega-fete ich handschuhen aus
also ich finde es eigentlich ganz neues
war geil jetzt geht jetzt auch gemacht
ich stelle das geht
[Musik]
ein über tellern ist groß bei fahnen zum
beispiel das ist megageil
das geht eigentlich gar nicht einmal so
machen wir das komische verdacht dass
ich direkt im müll das braucht auch
keinen halbwegs gut weil ich habe keinen
bock mehr
ehrlich das video hat mich komplett das
hat mein ganzes leben zerstört das war's
mit dem video das einzige was gut ist
die handschuhe sind halbwegs gut dass
ihr es gewesen das aber auch in ordnung
dieser predigt dingen da kann das fest
schon ne nun diese braucht man auch
nicht kennen kompletter müll meiner
meinung nach vielleicht habe ich mich
auch dumm angestellt ich weiß nicht aber
ich glaube nicht dass dann nach oben da
aktiviert die glocke aber in den kanal
check marktplatz ist in der videos
verlinkt und schreibt mir bei instagram
oder die kommentare weitere produkte die
ich bestellen soll für folgen wie zum
beispiel küchen gates teil 2 auf jeden
fall habe ich noch viele sachen bestellt
ich richte beiden mein zimmer
eingebremst nur mit milchprodukten das
was mit dem video wir sehen uns morgen
wieder um 19 uhr gibt es das video frau
schreien abonnieren favorisieren teilen
kommen ließ